[Applause]
I'm good you know I mentioned dude
where's my car is one of my favorite
movie titles is up there with Pootie
Tang I just heard that time like that's
that's a great movie title I heard this
rumor it was a while around for a while
that you guys were gonna make a sequel
and I love this this the title the
sequel was going to be
seriously dude where's my car it was
like it's like the second Godfather yeah
make it out do it yeah yeah yeah well
well well okay you've made a lot of
films which are the ones that fans
respond to most when they see you like
what films do when you when people
recognize you which ones they bring up
well I would think like American Pie or
the rundown but I had this thing but two
days ago I was flying from LA up here
and and I noticed that this lady and and
her little girl was like 7 years old was
sitting next to me and there they were
looking at me I was like oh cool I'm
getting recognized yeah so I look over
and they're both like oh my gosh oh my
gosh it's you we're your biggest fans
like alright this is awesome like this
is amazing this is amazing
look what it is look what it is and then
I'll send the little girl goes my sister
and I voted for you every single time
you competed on American Idol she was
she was I knew you're gonna be David
Archuleta I'm like I'm sorry yeah she
owes you're David Cooke right I go no
I'm like bull then who are you I go Sean
William Scott like oh what do you do I
go I'm an actor what kind of movies ago
the run down with the rock and they go
well we know the rock but we don't know
you I go dude where's my car
they didn't get that one I go ahead
American Pie and then the mom goes oh
that's Phil's remember we told little
Charlie what character do you play I go
pretty much the filthiest then I go I
did an animated film Ice Age too so and
then little girl goes that's not real
that's just voice work you didn't know
and then they she put those little ear
plugs in her in her ears and the little
goggles so she can sleep and they didn't
talk to me for five hours
because I wasn't David Cook yeah yeah
it's rough out there I love it when they
demand that you explain who you are
that's are you explain yourself
I've weird hair and I danced around at
12:30 at night not good enough give this
new movie out the promotion and in this
you play a grocery store manager yes
that right so what did first of all you
have you worked in a grocery store
before you have any experience or I've
never really worked anywhere I mean I've
had jobs but I just don't like to work
but I did work at Home Depot and you
worked at Home Depot yeah but I didn't I
didn't necessarily work there I just
like I would I would clock in and I
would just walk around and make myself
look busy
and most people at home bebote Home
Depot do this but I literally walk for
eight hours make I'll be right with you
go see Ryan and I own five and I would
walk for 8 hours constantly making
myself look busy but everybody else does
that too there's like 2 lifers that like
they have the tool belt so stuff like
that but I had no idea whatever it is so
depressing to the Home Depot people
there was so glad cuz I was working
there when I got American Pie and they
were so happy that I got the job not
because they actually wanted me to
succeed because I was leaving because I
was like such a waste of space like
there was no other way to get rid of you
it's finally gone we could have fired
him what oh yes we have a clip from the
promotion we should we should check out
and what Kate tell us about this John
see Riley's in the film and and and he
and I are both competing for this new
this new job and Jenna Fischer plays my
wife and and we basically have this
really crappy place and we're trying to
get out of him and it's a clip I think
where we keep hearing this guy play the
banjo and he hears us trying to have sex
and later I don't know if this clip
actually shows it but he ends up having
sex while playing the banjo so thank God
that's I don't that's a clip I don't
know now I wish we had just shown it
let's take this clip from the promotion
I'm the shoe in the leading shoe and
totally oh you're the leading shoo-in
yeah totally
community sweaty baths are sweaty
shoo-in I'm really sweaty I don't care
come here oh you stink I'll take a
shower okay hey guy you just give us a
break one night man we're trying to have
dinner the promotion opens Friday in
select cities really good to see you
yeah
[Applause]